I've got a watch I don't step on one
here doggies right here I love it
well welcome to Beaver met on it well
briefly backstage world friends before
today no but bringing people together I
feel like we're on opposing teams Oh
someone took my pom-poms away look at
all these dogs this is amazing I saw one
poop there there's a chair it was
awesome so you're working the big game
right who are you rooting for
well I'm rootin hey guy I wrote before
the can't see cheese come on I like the
initials so I'm in yeah it's a great
initial so I'm not usually one to like
be all up in sports well but I I love
when it's like challenging and it's like
neck and neck it's makes it more fun
that's always more fun yeah that's
competitive honey can I ask you
something sure so as somebody who
doesn't know when they're watching a
football game what they're actually
watching uh-huh you know other people
let us what should I be looking for Tony
what do I look for who do I look for do
I look for like offensive strategy do I
look for like defensive what am i would
give me some pointers do I just go for
food what something clever we can say
food is all good right oh yeah yeah
what's up yes just make it sound good
okay you guys know what an RPO is
totally you can go it on our POS player
[Music]
[Applause]
RPO is run past options so it's
something we say a lot in our business
you'll say look at the RPO here that
means the quarterback when he gets the
ball he can either have the run where he
does this yes and he can pull it away
they can pass or he can take off and run
it so we call that an RPO
that's me makes you sound smart go they
need more RP O's right now and get the
ball go tell me what a tight end does
what a tight end does yes let me show
you know embarrassing
[Applause]
you just made the Hall of Fame amazing
but even cooler you got father of the
year oh my god are you kids proud I hope
my kids proud there they were asking me
how the hell did you get that way but it
was good it was good I mean honestly one
of the biggest honors I've ever had in
my life they flew us out to New York we
did a whole presentation to people that
have received father of the year it goes
back 60 years presidents of our country
have received this award so it was very
cool and you have a new podcast right
yeah yeah I got a podcast called wide
open why do I get it and get it the
quick brown words yeah
but it's where I bring on guest people
people like yourselves movers and
shakers people from leaders of industry
actors athletes doctors and we talk
about leveling up being the best version
of yourself you know and yeah the
success leaves clues and I'd love to get
people's backstory and say okay what how
did you respond to how do you respond to
the critics how do you get out of a
depression you know how do you how do
you just get better and and then have
some fun with it so how do you deal with
it all yeah that's a great also what is
your workout routine or to know how you
think I want to go inside your brain I
just make my children ask and then let's
set them down and that's it so I asked
honor this too but what's your who's
your dream podcast person and if you say
hello cam it's awesome giving out good
relationship advice right
I would love Barack Obama I think rock
Obama
[Applause]
and in cement I've always loved from the
far as his mail stream officially
turning in songs my favorite person on
the show that is amazing she's she's you
know why I agreed to it she's got four
kids as well and just such a fascinating
career I think she I would listen to
that I'd want to know why like what
makes her take him what me to really
push herself that's a good one
but you know I've seen her do an
interview before several my stalker so
she was doing an interview and she was
talking about they asked her like what
is your secret Howie he's such a great
actress how do you get into the moment
so so well yeah and she was like I don't
know she literally said I don't know it
she was like I can't teach this and I
would love to be able to go on the show
and try to draw that out of her trying
to see exactly because there is
something there because now it's a name
but she probably had to work it you know
when she was like what what happened
when you started though that would be
the question don't you think that you do
you get into that mentality when you
play like when you when you play like
there's a good brain and maybe when you
perform like there's like the elements
of your brain that sort of shut off and
you focus I don't know well you do know
because you're you're a great actress
and you've done it before yeah you've
done it before and for anybody out there
watching like there's their techniques
to get into that flow that state of
where you can block out everything and
you're just absolutely present and
you're not really it's it's kind of like
not being afraid anymore how do you get
beyond that fear I always say life takes
off on the other side of fear and when
you can get to that point there's like
there's nothing you can accomplish and I
would love to see you see what Meryl has
a say about only 37 and no nothing but I
do feel like ego has a lot to do with it
I feel like you have to let go of your
ego and importance on everyone you know
I'm saying I know what I say about you
go yes a ego has no amigo it's that on a
pillow I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this